hoy se cumplen 100 días desde el inicio
de la invasión rusa ucrania y hasta hoy
el kremlin y ya controla el 20 por
ciento del territorio ucraniano la
situación en el terreno es devastadora
en cifras la guerra ha dejado más de
4200 civiles muertos según la onu entre
ellos 261 niños 5 millones de personas
que necesitan ayuda humanitaria
inmediata
6.8 millones de refugiados y 8 millones
de desplazados casi 260 mil
deportaciones forzadas hacia rusia de al
menos 13.000 casos en estudio por
posibles crímenes de guerra serían
568 mil millones de euros lo que
costaría la reconstrucción de ucrania si
la guerra se terminara hoy pero parece
que pues hoy no será el día final y para
ello entonces para analizar estos 100
días de guerra quiero saludar en este
momento nuestra primera invitada del día
ya susana mangana profesora e
investigadora del instituto de derechos
humanos de la universidad deusto bilbao
gracias susana por estar con nosotros
nuevamente en este espacio de france24
llamado directo américa hagamos primero
un balance hacia dónde vamos que han
sido estos 100 días de guerra
bien gracias a ti y raúl por nuevamente
contactarme y bueno no tenemos tanto
motivo para festejar como si lo tienen
en el palacio buckingham obviamente pero
realmente es un balance bastante gris
como tú decías no sólo por los números
sino también por lo que significa la
repercusión de esta guerra para el resto
del mundo no olvidemos que tanto rusia
como ucrania además de ser productores
de energía de gas de petróleo también
eran el granero como sabemos ahora de
buena parte del mundo y por tanto no hay
país que haya quedado a salvo de la
repercusión y del impacto negativo de
esta guerra que afecta sobre todo a los
que consumen trigo a los que consumen
también maíz no solo países en europa
como alemania como españa sino también
túnez o egipto es decir en el norte de
áfrica también hay países que se han
visto repercutido en una merma en lo que
son en la llegada a la importación de
los cereales importante que destacar que
esta guerra que es una guerra ya
calificada por los expertos en materia
de seguridad y de defensa como una
guerra de desgaste no hay visos de que
vaya a terminar para él todo parece
indicar que él creo en la apuesta por
morder y comer esta manzana a pedacitos
para evidentemente desgastar a las
autoridades minar la moral también del
pueblo y de las fuerzas ucranianas pero
sobre todo producir un impacto de
desgaste en selenski en las autoridades
ucranianas round claro en sus zonas y
también volviendo a ese tema que ya
seguramente vamos a ampliar en nuestra
conversación y la situación alimentaria
en áfrica es tan grave debido a la
guerra que hoy está conversando en sochi
con el presidente ruso vladimir putin el
presidente de la unión africana macky
sall pero eso lo vamos a tratar ahora
hablando del desgaste de esta guerra que
está jugando sobre todo en moscú pero
vivir celeste por ciento crearía nos
dice que promete una victoria pero la
onu dice que no va a haber ganadores
digamos como podemos vislumbrar el fin
de esta guerra será que realmente se van
a poder sentar otra vez estas partes en
la mesa para poder terminarla o
simplemente va a durar años digamos no
sé cómo la guerra en siria por ejemplo
ya que usted también tiene conocimiento
exactamente bueno estás poniendo
justamente el dedo en la llaga yo creo
que esto cada vez más se me parece o se
me antoja demasiado similar a la guerra
de desgaste que también hemos tenido y
continuamos teniendo en siria y de la
cual ya prácticamente como hay un
cansancio y una fatiga a nivel de medios
pero también de la población vamos a
decir de la comunidad internacional que
es un término muy laxo déjame decirte
que acabo de regresar de qatar de
oriente medio donde la guerra de ucrania
y de rusia no está presente es decir no
se ve un banderín no se ve un folleto no
hay mención a la guerra salvo por los
digamos noticieros obviamente
internacionales entre ellos france24 que
pude ver desde el hotel entonces ahí si
tienes información de la guerra de lo
contrario no es un tema de conversación
en las calles con lo cual yo mucho me
temo que se va a producir justamente una
fatiga de parte de la población que
venía siguiendo
las idas y vueltas los vericuetos de
esta guerra que es una guerra también de
narrativas y sobre todo porque en europa
ahora estamos adentrándonos en los meses
previos a las vacaciones estivales
países como españa como francia pero
también los propios alemanes tener que
salir de vacaciones no por ejemplo en
julio en agosto es cuando normalmente
las personas que son asalariados optan
por irse en familia de vacaciones y se
pierden mucho interés informativo y
sobre todo de este tipo de conflictos
pues que estamos en un punto muerto
volverán a sentarse a la mesa de
negociación todo indica que por ahora no
hay razón para que putin quiera negociar
nada con helen sí porque viene ganando
más lentamente de lo que hubiera deseado
pero está controlando como tú decías el
20 por ciento del territorio ucraniano
ya controla la salida desde ucrania al
mar de azov hay una continuidad
geográfica marítima ahora con la
península de crimea que ocupó
ilegalmente en el 2014 recordemos
todavía ucrania retiene la salida al mar
por odessa una importante ciudad
portuaria para los ucranianos pero
evidentemente no parece que se vaya a
sentar a negociar ni tanto celestini
tampoco autoridades relevantes de rusia
y yo lo llamo a esto la teoría de la
pecera raúl que sigue sin con esto
europapress eeuu le han dado armas a
ucrania suficientes para resistir para
defenderse para que kiev por ejemplo la
capital ucraniana no cayera ante los
tanques y el asedio ruso sin embargo no
le dan las ansiadas armas de largo
alcance porque en realidad el presidente
bailén tiene temor también de que celan
si decida autorizar a sus generales que
las utilicen y sobrevuelen y lleguen e
impacten a territorio ruso con lo cual
ahí sería una declaración de guerra en
los eeuu y rusia que es lo que se ha
querido evitar desde el inicio de esta
contienda por eso yo le llamo la tesis
de la pecera alimentan al pez que sería
ucrania lo suficiente para que siga
viviendo en esta pecera cada vez que
saca ivo que le dan alimento pero no lo
suficiente como para que gane incline la
balanza de la guerra a su favor y esto
es lo que ocurrió exactamente con
aquellos que intentaban de sacar y
derrocar al gobierno de bashar al assad
en síria con lo cual tu metáfora o el
símil que has hecho con la comparación
con siria yo creo que es pertinente pues
susana eso en el ámbito militar y no
quiero que terminemos nuestra
conversación sin hablar por supuesto del
lado civil los refugiados los
desplazados los muertos los presuntos
crímenes de guerra también cometidos por
los rusos usted también ha estado
involucrada en después ayuda a los
refugiados conversamos lo conversamos en
una oportunidad precisamente aquí en
este espacio de france24 cuál es la
situación actual de los refugiados y
hasta donde podemos ver tanto tanta
mortandad
bueno efectivamente ahí también sigo
involucrada con redes de apoyo y de
contacto entre ucranianos y ciudadanos
por ejemplo vascos aquí en el territorio
del país vasco donde me encuentro en
bilbao donde hay muchísimas iniciativas
solidarias galas benéficas actuaciones
de danza festivales de música en los que
he podido participar algunos de ellos
para recoger fondos por ejemplo para
organizar campamentos de verano a los
que puedan acudir los menores los niños
ucranianos con otros niños vascos y
buscar así una integración más idónea
más sana para estas personas que muchos
de ellos extrañan a la familia extraña
en una abuela extrañan a sus padres por
ejemplo recordemos que muchos de los
hombres su cráneos han tenido que
permanecer la mayoría sino en el frente
de batalla así para poder trabajar y
sostener el país a la familia con lo
cual es una situación dramática muchas
de estas personas vinieron sin saber
realmente cuánto tiempo iban a quedarse
y ahora empiezan a acusar el cansancio
de estar viviendo fuera de su entorno
familiar y a pesar de que hay apoyo a
pesar de que se han abierto clases aulas
de castellano y también de apoyo con
tareas escolares tanto para las madres
muchas son madres jóvenes soy para los
menores pues evidentemente estas
personas quieren regresar a sus hogares
y claro la guerra es una guerra que no
termina que es una guerra de desgaste y
además que muchas veces cuando regresan
a aquellas ciudades como por ejemplo
harkov ha sido arrebatada a los rusos
por los ucranianos raúl se encuentran
con escuelas destrozadas con el edificio
maltrecho a punto de colapsar y de
derrumbe con lo cual no es fácil para
estas familias tampoco regresar a
ucrania que ve contraída su economía en
un 45 por ciento pues susana se nos
quedan muchísimas cosas en el tintero
obviamente para resumir estos 100 días
de guerra y además lo que viene igual
siempre es para mí y para nosotros todo
el equipo de directo américa de francés
y 4 que estés aquí invitada en nuestro
programa se usan un gran abrazo nos
vemos en una próxima oportunidad
hablaremos porque hoy mismo he estado de
una conferencia sobre cómo interpretar
las migraciones en el marco legal de la
unión europea y hay demasiadas lagunas
raúl hay que trabajar mucho más ese tema
de las migraciones así es un gran abrazo